to present the directing award here is
one of the first ladies of the screen a
beautiful and versatile actress who
recently opened a fortune cookie and
found a fortune inside for Warner
Brothers are you sure mamasan Roslyn
Russell
Robert Roz welcome home from Tokyo Tokyo
Bob where we shot the whole thing to
right here in Burbank you didn't why are
you so surprised after all you and being
just made a picture about Hong Kong you
shot the whole thing in London yeah well
we had to we couldn't get studio space
and Rome yes I can and now ladies and
gentlemen the five nominees for the best
achievements in Direction are J Lee
Thompson for the Guns of Navarone Robert
Russell for the hustler Stanley Kramer
for judgment at Nuremburg federico
fellini
full adulterer DITA Robert wises and
Jerome Robbins for West Side Story
vanilla and the winners are Robin
I don't thank you very very much for
this honor
I appreciate it deeply and I want to
thank heartily all the scores of
wonderful people artists technicians
writers musicians all who did such a
tremendous job in helping us look West
Side Story up on the screen thank you
I'd like to thank the producers of the
movie and also the producers of the
original play our prints and the late
Bob Griffiths